.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
WE BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT,
THE DOW JONES INDUSTRIAL IS
OFFICIALLY NOW IN NEGATIVE
TERRITORY COMPARED TO WHEN
JOE BIDEN TOOK OFFICE, NOW
CLOSING BELOW 30,000, THE LOWEST
CLOSING OF HIS PRESIDENCY --
MORTGAGE INFLATION, THE PRICE
HIKES ARE AS BAD AS EVER AND
WHILE BIDEN IS DISMISSING THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A RECESSION, THE
FEARS ON WALL STREET, THEY ARE
GROWING LOUDER AND LOUDER.
ALL WHILE CONSUMER SPENDING IS
NOW RUNNING OUT OF STEAM, COMMON
SENSE AMERICANS ARE CONTINUING
TO SUFFER NEEDLESSLY, ALL
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN'S FAILING
FAR LEFT RADICAL ECONOMIC AND
ANTI-FOSSIL FUEL AGENDA.
FROM GAS PUMP PRICES TO THE
GROCERY AISLE, 401(K)s, BY HIS
FAILURES NOW ARE AS UNDENIABLE
AS EVER.
AS OBVIOUS AS EVER, AND FRANKLY,
AS DANGEROUS AS EVER.
SUCH AN ITEM GOING TO START BY
ASKING A COUPLE OF VERY SIMPLE
AND A COUPLE OF VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD QUESTIONS.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ONE
PRESIDENT, ONE ADMINISTRATION,
FAILED AS MUCH THIS PAST?
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN MORE
INCOMPETENCE, MORE BAD POLICY,
MORE OUTRIGHT LYING THAN WHAT WE
ARE NOW SEEING FROM JOE BIDEN
AND THE DESTRUCTIVE DEMOCRATIC
AGENDA?
LITERALLY ON A DAY-TO-DAY BASIS.
RECORD HIGH GAS PRICES, 41 YEAR
HIGH INFLATION, RECKLESS
SPENDING, WEAK.
I MEAN VERY WEAK, PATHETICALLY
WEAK DIPLOMACY ABROAD,
ABANDONING OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
BEHIND ENEMY LINES IN THE
ISLAMIC EMIRATES OF AFGHANISTAN,
RISING CRIME, BABY FORMULA
SHORTAGE, WERE LIGHTLESS ATTACKS
ON, REFUSING TO CONDEMN
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES AND THE
DOXXING OF THEIR HOMES AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR CHURCHES.
A COMPLETE CATASTROPHE AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER, AND A COMPLETE
DISCONNECT FROM REALITY.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS ONLY 18
MONTHS INTO HIS PRESIDENCY.
WE GOT A WHOPPING TWO AND A HALF
YEARS TO GO BECAUSE WHILE
JOE BIDEN'S ADMINISTER RATION
TRIES TO TOUT THEIR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY, ALL OF YOU, EVERYDAY
AMERICANS, YOUR STRUGGLES TELL
US ALL A VERY, VERY DIFFERENT
STORY, DOESN'T IT?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK I WAS WRONG THEN
ABOUT THE PATH THAT INFLATION
WOULD TAKE.
♪ ♪
>> INFLATION NOW RUNNING AT
8.6%, THE HIGHEST SINCE 1981.
AND AMERICANS ARE GETTING
SQUEEZED.
>> DRIVERS ARE FRUSTRATED AS THE
U.S. REACHES ANOTHER NEW RECORD
ON GAS PRICES.
>> $140 TO FILL UP MY VAN.
THAT [BLEEP] CRAZY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN: I'M DOING
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO BLUNT
PUTIN'S GAS PRICE HIKE.
>> THIS SUMMER IS GOING TO BE
ROUGH, I WILL BE HONEST WITH
YOU.
>> EVERY TIME YOU GO AND SHOP
THE PRICE OF SOMETHING HAS GONE
UP BY SO MUCH, IT'S INSANE.
>> A DISASTROUS REPORT LAST WEEK
SHOWING PRICES SURGING ACROSS
THE ENTIRE ECONOMY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN: MY PLAN FOR
THE ECONOMY MADE EXTORT HER
PROGRESS.
>> IS HURT ME BAD.
>> TO
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN: I DON'T WANT
TO HEAR ANYMORE THESE LIES ABOUT
RECKLESS SPENDING.
WE ARE CHANGING PEOPLE'S LIVES.
>> Sean: THAT'S HOW YOU GET A
32% APPROVAL RATING.
GET THIS NEW POLL FROM RASMUSSEN
FINDING WITH THE ISSUES AT THE
TOP OF MINDS OF INDEPENDENT
VOTERS, INFLATION, THE ECONOMY,
VIOLENT CRIME, THE ISSUES
DEMOCRATS SEEM TO CARE ABOUT THE
LEASE, BUT RATHER THAN ADMIT
FAILURE, RATHER THAN DO THE
SENSIBLE THING, REVERSE COURSE,
CHANGE POLICY, THE BIDEN TEAM,
THEY JUST DOUBLED DOWN ON DUMB
AND DUMBER AND STUPID AND MORE
FAR LEFT LUNACY LIKE ATTACKS ON
U.S. ENERGY INDEPENDENCE AND
OVERSEEING MORE THAN A DOUBLING
OF THE GAS PRICES FROM THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
GREEN NEW DEAL SOCIALISM,
ATTACKS ON FOSSIL FUELS, THIS IS
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD
ECONOMY.
ATTACKS ON OUR BORDER PATROL IS
NOW WE HAVE THE LARGEST CARAVAN
TO DATE MARCHING THEIR WAY RIGHT
TOWARDS THE BORDER.
ATTACKS ON PARENTS.
WHY?
THEY DARED TO STAND UP TO
LEFT-WING INDOCTRINATION IN
SCHOOLS AND TALK ABOUT
AGE-APPROPRIATE EDUCATION FOR
THEIR KIDS, DEMANDING EXCELLENCE
IN TEACHING WHEN WE ARE FAILING
THEM AT A SPECTACULAR LEVEL.
JOEY HIMSELF REFUSING TO CONDEMN
ATTACKS AGAINST PRO-LIFE
CENTERS.
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF THEM.
WHITE HOUSE STATEMENT THIS WEEK
WAS TEPID, WEAK, PATHETIC, NOT
GOOD ENOUGH, JOE.
AND IT COMES AS BIDEN IS NOW
CONTINUING TO MAKE ONE BIZARRE
BLUNDER AFTER ANOTHER.
HERE'S A SMALL SAMPLE OF JOEY,
YOUR PRESIDENT, THE PAST 48
HOURS, INCLUDING THIS COMMENT
ABOUT A CFO WHO RECENTLY PASSED
AWAY.
SEE IF YOU WOULD MAYBE SAY AT
THE SAME.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN: I'M ALSO
PROUD TO SIGN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
MY FIRST AN OFFICE TO COMBAT
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST LGBTQ
LI -- EXCUSE ME PLUS AMERICANS.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN: BY THE WAY,
MY SIMPLE THESE TEAR FAMILIES
OF -- YOUR CFO WHO DROPPED DEAD
VERY UNEXPECTEDLY, MY BEST TO
THEIR FAMILIES, TOUGH STUFF.
>> Sean: JUST DROPPED DEAD
RATHER UNEXPECTED LEE.
WEAK, FRAIL, COGNITIVE RECORD,
OUT OF TOUCH COME OUT TO LUNCH.
WHY PEOPLE LIKE DAVID AXELROD,
VAN JONES, AND EVEN DON LEMON
STARTING TO BE HONEST ABOUT IT.
ONLY TWO YEARS BEHIND ME IN THE
SHOW.
WE WERE WARNING EVERYBODY DURING
THE CAMPAIGN IT WAS OBVIOUS, IT
WAS TRANSPARENT, WE WERE TELLING
PEOPLE WHILE HE WAS HIDING IN
HIS BASEMENT BUNKER YOU COULD
STILL SEE HE WAS A COGNITIVE
MASS AND WEAK AND FRAIL.
AND GET THIS, AND EXPLOSIVE NEW
PIECE FROM THE FAR LEFT ATLANTIC
ENTITLED "WHY BIDEN SHOULDN'T
RUN IN 2024.
THE ARTICLE BEGINS "LET ME PUT
THIS BLUNTLY, JOE BIDEN SHOULD
NOT RUN FOR REELECTION IN 2024.
HE IS TOO OLD."
IF HE'S TOO CHECKED OUT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT AGE.
LISTEN, I THINK ANYBODY CAN
GIVE -- BERNIE SANDERS CAN GIVE
ANYBODY A RUN FOR THEIR MONEY.
HE'S OLD, HE'S NOT CHECKED OUT.
IS NOT A COGNITIVE MESS.
ANYWAY, THE FAR LEFT MEDIA MOB,
THEY ARE BEING FORCED TO NOW
GRAPPLE WITH WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
SHOWING YOU NIGHT AFTER NIGHT,
TRYING TO WARN YOU ABOUT,
JOE BIDEN IS UNFIT FOR THIS
OFFICE.
SADLY, HE'S UNFIT TO BE THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AND IN MY
OPINION, THAT IS THE TOUGHEST
JOB IN THE WORLD.
HERE'S JOEY EARLIER TODAY
APPEARING TOTALLY ALOOF AND
IGNORING MORE QUESTIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DID BUSINESS WITH HER SON.
>> [INDISCERNIBLE].
♪ ♪
>> WHAT ARE YOU AFRAID OF?
>> Sean: AT LEAST THIS TIME
WHEN HE TURNED TO SHAKE SOME
BUDDIES AND THERE WAS ACTUALLY
SOMEBODY THERE.
RATHER THAN RESET -- RATHER THAN
ADMIT FAILURE, RATHER THAN
ADMIT -- CHANGE COURSE, OFFER
REAL SOLUTIONS, BIDEN, THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY JUST PLAY
ONE BLAME GAME AFTER ANOTHER.
THEY BLAME SO-CALLED BIG OIL,
THEY BLAME THE PANDEMIC, THEY
BLAME PUTIN, THEY BLAME
CORPORATIONS, MEET COMPANIES,
WHICH PEOPLE, AND WHEN ALL ELSE
FAILS, JUST BLAME DONALD TRUMP
AND BY THE WAY, DON'T FORGET
BLAME FOX NEWS.
IT GETS EVEN BETTER BECAUSE
SPEAKER PELOSI IS APPARENTLY
TRAPPED IN A TIME WARP AND IS
NOW BLAMING ALL OF THIS ON THE
WAR IN IRAQ.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WITH ALL THE CONSTRAINTS THAT
COVID -- WE HAVE THE WAR IN
IRAQ, WITH COVID, CHIVES REALLY
DETERRED MORE PRODUCT COMING
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: SHE'S NOT FAR BEHIND
JOEY.
YOU'VE GOT KAMALA ONE HEARTBEAT
AWAY FROM THE PRESIDENCY, PELOSI
THIRD IN LINE.
GOD HELP US.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
COSTS ARE RISING BECAUSE OF
JOE BIDEN AND THE GREEN NEW DEAL
CLIMATE CULTISTS INSIDE THE NEW
GREENDALE SOCIALIST PARTY WHO
ARE RUNNING THE SHOW.
JOE BIDEN ARTIFICIALLY REDUCED
THE WORLD'S SUPPLY OF OIL,
KILLED THE PIPELINE, SUPPORTED
BURDENSOME REGULATIONS TO MAKE
IT HARDER AND HARDER TO DRILL
AND FRACK, HE HAS BEEN ENDLESSLY
ATTACKED THE U.S. OIL INDUSTRY,
EVEN TALKING ABOUT SENDING
EXECUTIVES TO JAIL.
FOR WHAT?
FOR MAKING MONEY?
FOR PRODUCING WHAT WE NEED AS A
SOCIETY TO FUNCTION?
THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE WORLD'S
ECONOMY?
NOW HE'S HEADED TO SAUDI ARABIA.
THE NUMBER HE CALLED
SAUDI ARABIA A PARIAH COUNTRY
DURING THE CAMPAIGN ALL WELL
DEMOCRATS, YOU KNOW, OVERHEATED
THE ECONOMY WITH THE SO-CALLED
AMERICAN RESCUE PACKAGE THAT
CAUSED EVEN MORE MASSIVE
INFLATION.
THEY SAY THAT HE'S NOT GOING TO
BEG THE CROWN PRINCE TO PRODUCE
MORE OIL.
THEY SAY THAT.
HE ACCUSED THE CROWN PRINCE OF
KILLING THE JOURNALIST
JAMAL KHASHOGGI.
IS HE GOING TO SAY IT TO HIS
FACE?
I TEND TO DOUBT IT BECAUSE HE
WANTS SAUDI OIL.
AMERICANS ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY
THEIR BILLS ALL BECAUSE OF
JOE BIDEN.
RECESSION FEARS ARE GROWING
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN.
FINANCIAL MARKETS ARE SPOOKED
AND TANKING BECAUSE OF
JOE BIDEN.
INFLATION IS DRAINING THE
SAVINGS AND RETIREMENT FUNDS OF
AMERICANS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
TWO-THIRDS OF AMERICANS NOW
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK
BECAUSE OF JOE BIDEN.
RISING GAS PRICES.
THAT'S A BURDEN FOR BUSINESS,
THAT'S A BURDEN FOR ALL OF US.
FOR FAMILIES -- ALL CAUSED BY
BIDEN AND HIS NEW GREENDALE
SOCIALIST COMRADES.
NOW ADD TO THAT A MASSIVE
INCREASE IN MORTGAGE RATES.
THAT MEANS IF YOU WANT TO
PURCHASE A HOME, IT'S GOING TO
BECOME MORE UNAFFORDABLE FOR
MANY AND SALES OF EXISTING
HOMES, THEY ARE ALREADY
PLUMMETING.
NEW HOME CONSTRUCTION, IT'S
ABOUT TO COME TO A SCREECHING
HALT.
FEWER AND FEWER AMERICANS WILL
REFINANCE THEIR HOMES, PROPERTY
VALUES -- I KNOW YOU THOUGHT YOU
COULD SELL YOUR HOME A YEAR AGO
FOR A LOT MORE MONEY.
THEY ARE ABOUT TO PLUMMET.
WITH PROBABLY NOTABLE
EXCEPTIONS, STATES THAT MAY NOT
BE HIT AS HARD, FLORIDA, TEXAS,
TENNESSEE, THE CAROLINAS.
WHY WON'T THEY BE HIT AS HARD?
BECAUSE THERE'S A TON OF PEOPLE
LEAVING DEEP BLUE STATES LIKE
NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY AND
ILLINOIS AND CALIFORNIA AND THEY
ARE MOVING TO THOSE STATES.
SO DEMAND WILL REMAIN HIGHER.
BUT WE ARE SEEING IS A COMPLETE
DEVOLUTION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THE PARTY THAT IS NOW HELL-BENT
ON DECLINE AND DESTRUCTION AND
SO ADDICTED TO THEIR CULT, THEY
WON'T -- THEY WILL NOT EVEN
CONSIDER CHANGING COURSE.
YOU HAVE A PARTY CREATED, ONE
BIG FAR LEFT POLITICAL COCKTAIL,
AND THAT'S CREATING ONE BAD
CRISIS AFTER ANOTHER.
THE WASHINGTON SWAMP
COAST-TO-COAST, FLYOVER COUNTRY,
CITY TO CITY, EVERYWHERE IN
BETWEEN.
WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE IN CHARGE,
COSTS GO UP, CRIME GOES UP,
QUALITY OF LIFE GOES DOWN AND
YOU MAKE LESS MONEY.
JUST LOOK AT THE FAILING FAR
LEFT D.A. OUT IN LOS ANGELES,
THE SKY GEORGE GASCON.
HE'S NOW BEING EXPOSED YET
AGAIN.
AS WE ARE NOW LEARNING, THE GANG
MEMBER ACCUSED OF MURDERING TWO
POLICE OFFICERS IN L.A. COUNTY
THIS WEEK -- OH, THIS GUY HAS A
LONG RAP SHEET STILL OUT ROAMING
THE STREETS AFTER BEING GIVEN A
LENIENT PLEA BARGAIN BY HIS
OFFICE LAST YEAR.
WHAT WAS THE CHARGE?
A WEAPONS CHARGE.
UP IN OREGON, A NEW
INVESTIGATION FROM FOX NEWS
FINDS THAT THE STATE'S EFFORT TO
DECRIMINALIZE DRUGS HAS NOW
BECOME ONE BIG ON MITIGATED
DISASTER.
ACCORDING TO OUR VERY OWN
DAN SPRINGER, 16 MONTHS INTO
THIS FIRST IN THE NATION
EXPERIMENT, THE NUMBERS PAINT A
VERY BLEAK PICTURE.
DRUG OVERDOSE DEATHS NOW HIT AN
ALL-TIME HIGH IN 2021.
1,069.
THAT IS A 41% INCREASE FROM 2020
WHILE REPORTEDLY VERY FEW PEOPLE
ARE SEEKING TREATMENT.
SO ASK YOURSELF, WHY WOULD ANY
COMMUNITY WANT TO ENABLE HARD
DRUG USE HE MET YOU'RE BASICALLY
HELPING PEOPLE KILL THEMSELVES.
WHY WOULD ANY COMMUNITY WANT TO
PUT THE INTERESTS OF HARD DRUG
USERS OVER THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY OF ORDINARY CITIZENS,
AND WHEN THEY ARE HIRED WASTED
AND OUT OF THEIR MINDS, THEY
COME INTO CONTACT WITH PEOPLE
GOING ABOUT THEIR DAILY CHORES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEMOCRATIC
PLAYBOOK, LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS
HAVE NOW BECOME THE ENEMY.
COMMON SENSE AMERICANS ARE NOW
IN THE CROSSHAIRS OF THIS NEW
EXTREME FAR LEFT SOCIALIST
DEMOCRATIC DISASTER, A PARTY
THAT CODDLED VIOLENT CRIMINALS,
A PARTY THAT PUTS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS OVER AMERICANS.
YEAH, THEY GET PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT, AND A FREE PHONE, YOU
ALSO GET FREE TRANSPORTATION.
YOU GET A PARTY THAT PUTS FAR
LEFT CLIMATE FANTASIES OVER
MIDDLE-CLASS STABILITY, A PARTY
THAT KEEPS PUTTING AMERICA LAST
UNDER THE LOGIC OF BIDEN AND THE
DEMOCRATS, WE CAN'T DRILL MORE
OIL HERE AT HOME, BUT WE CAN BEG
SAUDI ARABIA, IRAN, VENEZUELA,
AND OPEC TO PUMP MORE?
UNDER THAT LOGIC OF BIDEN, WE
CAN'T LOWER GAS PRICES NOW, BUT
WE CAN ALL SWITCH AND BUY
ELECTRIC CARS OVERNIGH